ます
い
あ
え半になりましたのでえ午後の午始めたい
と思います午後のめにってえにごをお願い
します
amp
[音楽]
U
パ
[音楽]
AMB
ン
[音楽]
AMB
シ
ン
[音楽]
ody
AMBU
ござい
ますさ長あのはい今日の方法はあの
村さんにお任せいたし
ますめて
あ
はい
こんにちははい
え今日はですね
あのウかさいうあのせなる日にちになった
んですねあのテ教会としてきはこのま
さほど住まのさちろがお
たり
え湿みたいねまお祭りみたい格好で今日は
あのこう
いうセレモニが行って
ますあのウサというあの言葉からちょっと
私のお話を
で
あの
っこ
えあはあの
らほど手にあの
K
て
ますはあの本当に
と
まあ皆さんよく知ってるかもしれませんが
あの先生学先生
のがんでるない
スジあの先生学のついてある名前あります
ねあの
それそういう名前から
元々あのりた名みたい
ねクシ
Son
か同じ日に行ってますということが
おっしゃってました
での方が
まさにはあの聖なるね1年の中で聖なる
一番せ
なる大事なて思って
ますなか言うと仏教の方々についておさ様
が悟ったのは一番大事なないんでしょうか
なの
でらのでまだで
で
おの
とおさ様が悟った日ということで大事だと
思っ
てそういう儀式とか色々なお祭りとか行っ
てるんです
あと
はあの仏教としてキンダーが使っている
あのシリーランカとかタのねで
あで
もランのランのシの本がてそのの本もマと
いう本の名前ですねその本の中でもお釈迦
様の
Ook
が
ねも
せグ68っての
はからまるいうことですねらしねん
ことQ
でそういう加え方があります
えなのでま昔から見ると昔の歴史から見る
とまそういう念が稼いることも上さになっ
てましたのでそういう大事なこともあり
ますま仏教ということでもさ様の悟った日
ということでもありましてまそういうこと
でもありますえ
だからまずは私の話ではこういうの話は
ここで終わってこれから
は皆さんはよくテはでブのスてるなねテブ
はマナ気をつけた方が言うというポイント
がまないくつかていうじゃなくて1つ
ちょっとできる
だるッは学ぶとき大事なポイントというか
まどういうことかと言う
と日本人
は日本人だけでなくてあの他の外国人の
から見るとも自分の国の号は自分のぶかに
かわってますね例えば日本人日本語日本語
にから見ると
日本語は多分中国とかま日本語の単語とか
ね昔からの日本語の仏教日本の仏教の
関わりもあって作った感じとかこの漢字に
合わせてあるイメージがあるんです
ねからそういう
イメージねいて日本人はまこの例えば漢字
で書くとこういうどんなイメージかどんな
イメージかとか日本人は大体まあ感じ見た
途端分かり
ますそれは多分通訳すると翻訳するとま
そのイメージはそのまま翻訳するかする
ことができますかま大体できない場合が
多いと思います
例えば
ば日本人
は教で
も
テラ
PAのその言葉
がそのまま
するのは日本語とか英語とかどこでも本に
するのはしても%に
満点尊することができるかちょっと難しい
と思います例えばねパリゴから見る
と
マ
パゴのばはあで本当にろなみ
でご
ます
みの
の1番の意味ではねまよう意味では言うと
1番なのはお釈迦様のえていう意味ですん
です
けどあの
.
[音楽]
はま外難かしいということです例えば法と
いうか法の法の感じで使っていつも翻訳し
ていますねそうですけれどもパリゴである
分である芸であるところで同じ意味でま
読めないとあり
ますあとはどどかっていうのはま
ぐという
意味があります
ねどかては本当に英語でもサリンというか
ま翻されてありますけれどもま本当
にパリゴのどかという言葉で入ってる意味
はそのままするのはもしなかで
と我々
が幸せと思っていることも
[音楽]
るれてれてでも生まれることは皆さんから
のまそんなにどかっいうことでよかせと
いうことですかねそういう風に本当にま
そういう文化とかそういう
あ時代お釈迦様の時代その時代のブンカ
そののソティそののニの
ばとなどのちっとまっきりわかないとた
ない
が仏教とか日本の仏教とかという使ってる
言葉がよくあってこれはそのままあ多分
英語とかでんするとま本当に元々の意味が
出られない場合が多いと思います例えば
あのあの日本せて言ったりどういう意味
ですか幸せ幸せという場合はま色々な幸せ
がありますねだって子供の幸せとか大人の
幸せとか宗教的な幸せとかって言ったら
どのだからあるね子供はどこでっているか
まご飯を食べてお腹がいっぱいな幸せに
なりましたっ
てそれも
幸せ日本日本日本人がすっているところね
そういう風にパリゴでもある場で多分本当
に1つの意味で本にされない場合
が多いと思いますだからそのところ
ちょっと気をつけた方がいいと思うますね
皆さん本とか呼んだま先生は興の中でそれ
はもう説法の中でそれはちゃんと教えられ
ていますで皆さん本とかなんともテキスト
とか読んでいたりするとそういう場合が
ちょっと気をつけてくださいということ
ですねあこの場ではここの意味は何
でしょう
かまそれはどんな合でもあるもんですね
おさ様の時代で使ってい
た立話今の日本人はとかそういう文化
分からない人の分からない場合が多いと
思いますで話は本当にその文化に合わせて
いうものですね日本の立話は日本人は大体
わかります日本の文化とか合せて住人と色
て言ったらま言葉から見ると住人と
いる意味としては人々の違う
ねこ言葉じゃなくて人々は住人とい色々な
色々こというばだけるとあ
と色があるですじゃないねそういうにパで
もあるこの
まで
でるの
[音楽]
かとで
ないからこれは本当にま皆さんよく頑張っ
ていてテキストなどを読みたい場合は本当
にま先に私は今日はま長い法は長い話はし
ないと思ってますけどあのこういう1つの
気をつけてつけるというポイントだけえ
教えたいと思っていましたあとはもう1つ
なんですけどそれで私のえそれ終わって
から私のお話は
あ終わりになりますでテラードで
は目的としてまあデ
ね
る
てハはま日本人の日本語の言葉でネハンと
言います
バ
で
わはよくと聞いたことがあり
ますの言葉ま私もま日本人の友達から聞い
たんだけどまるなっては日本人はよくま
知っ
てるそれ
ンて
えネとかニとか
パゴで
バもテ
で一般の方の我々誰でも最後の目的になっ
て
ますその
め
れが
てて
so
すくことができますという釈迦様のあとか
れた言葉にありますでそれ
で昔昔はお釈迦様
があ
すごいなんというかあの今のテキスト
のパリ号のテキスト見ると本当にすごい
いっぱい本があります
まま本当に命の中で読む終わることができ
ないぐらい真っ暗と思いますねみ大体読む
とパリゴ
でですけど一番最初の時おさ様がまそれ
線分で合わせてま簡単に言うて言うのはま
先ほどま初めは
生り
簡単にでもこれは本当に難しいことなん
ですけどまそれま
すごいテね
テでか
ょ
かっ
らさお
の芸の最の分になって
ます
で
まあもない
かねはでてたらテ
みのは
て
テ何でしょうか聞いたらなんとか返事簡単
に日本人に
簡単に説明できる返事がありますかで
こっちの方がいいんじゃないんです
かちょっとまま日本の仏教のか宗教は
あんまり信じていない人宗教の関係が
あんまりない人がま多分たまにいますね
日本にで私にもあったことがありますそう
いう方
がうんまこういう色は何です
かなぜこれは聞いてますかとかいう色々説
がありますそしてま私テ
のさどういう仏教ですかどんな教です
か日本の仏教でどんな違いがありますかと
いう風に色々質問がありますねそういう
からそやてすると簡単に言うとこちらの
内容は何でしょう
か聞いたら私はこのげ
ででる
だけますおかさは本当
にまま全てのパープねパパかられてこころ
がね言ねく
ここ
がするがこと本当にてではま心が大事だと
思って心な心が清らかにするということが
大事ということで煩悩が煩悩から離れて心
が清らかなするということ大事だと思って
教えているあ宗教ということでまこの方に
教えてあげます
でまこ
パパまげ
の
すごいま細かいところまでま先生
YOU
もは本当にみたいでまそんなに難しい話は
私から
が
[音楽]
さんブテわ
どや
て
わがされた方がいいという考え
がちょっと考えために話し聞きたいと思っ
てたま皆さんま多分今でも皆さんの頭の中
で
が
がるとあこれよるこのここのことでみんに
介された方がいいなとか
ねね本当にね本当に我々がれ
で
てんなたらじゃないんですかねま本当に聞
たまこういうこういう色々色
話
は
でない初心者の方に初心者っていうかね
全然は知れない方ねあ
教えるために紹介されるために何が答えが
あった方がいいと思ってえそいうまげの
サパげのまはまめした以上の先生の本など
も見てあそういう風になんとかちゃんと
返事があった方がいいと思いますだから
こういうことで私の話はこちらでいようと
思いますでまいたかったのはまテはスなで
みは本当に気をつけることです文化とか
言葉とか単語とかま本当に集約されるのは
難かしいということで気をつけて読んで
くださいということとま2番目は本当にテ
やてるる
て
あ
ののポイントがつ2つだけはいたかったん
ですで本当にねま
たまにれ
ちょっと違うんですけれどもあえというま
もうなんでしたっけ言うも分からない
ぐらいありますねなんだから
人いんですも
たしてどういうことでしょうかとか聞き
たい人もいますねだからそういう人がもし
あったらまその方にえ本当に我々がやって
いるのはこれでしょうって
いうが
がての
はで
はがいいと思ってそういう2つのポイント
があ私あ説明してそれで私の話はこれで
以上と思いますま私の話を聞いてくれて
本当に誠にありがとうござい
ますえ申し訳ないんですが日本語とかあま
他の間違ったところが多かったと思います
がまそれでも申し訳ございません
はいありがとうございますもうちょっと
時間ありね私は45分までです
か
うんでは
あの昨日のえフアで
あの喋ったことを
のすじゃなくて
省略また再び繰り返したいと思い
ます
でこの生命生きるっていうことはま
ものすごく理解しにくい難しいこと
で仏教ではね廻という言葉すかってが限り
なく回転するんですね命はで現代知識的に
は
このま宇宙がビッバンで現われてそれから
また椅か壊れてしまいますその時ほんの
わかな時間で生命が現われるという話をし
てますけど僕は逆に取ってるんですね生命
はもう転しながら原に流れるんでその間で
ま時々宇宙が現れたりま消えたりはす
ますだからお強てみるとこう
宇宙は1個現れて消える時間1項と言って
こって言ってねえパリゴでカップて言うん
ですけどねそれはま無数にかえちゃうん
です
ねだからあの現代用語ではビッグベンから
ビッランチまで仏教では1とるんですねで
他の稼
方までとこれでこの1億2億3億兆と稼い
ちゃうと相当長い
でしょだからその時点でブッダの
理解知識範にねどれど大きどれほど大きい
かっていうことはま分かります
ねそこで生命はあの次元ここの座りまして
ねでそれで我々知ってるのはこの3次元の
生命だけなんですねだからで今科学者たち
がこのアストロフィジスの人々はあの宇宙
に他の惑星に生命があるのかないのかとか
研究したりするそういう人々はこの三次源
物質世界の形の生命を探しているんですね
で仏教のこの心のの生命次元ではま3次元
に入ってるのはほんのわかなんです人間と
展開と地獄の生命だけ
ですが3次元じゃないんですで次元であっ
ても地獄の生命は見ること不可能で展開の
生命は見ることもできないんですし
ねということはこの我々のか目にうる光線
は話してないということでま確実に生き
てるんだと見えないからないって話では
ないんだから
ねでそこ
で生命の則見ると
この1人1人に心があるんです
ねこの1人1人の心が必死で生きを生きを
してるん
ですだから私も必死で生きをしている皆様
方も必死でとにかく生きようと思ってるん
です
ねこのそんなにも生きよう生きようと思っ
てるのおかし生けてるだから
ねそこで何か変なところあるんで例えば
とにかく呼吸しましょうとにかく呼吸し
ましょう何が何でも呼吸だけしましょうと
いう風な我々思ってないんですとにかく
呼吸が起きてるんだから
ね生きることもとにかく生きてるんだから
気楽に生きればいいでしょうねそれだけは
そうじゃないんですねとにかく生きてい
なくちゃあかんやとか
ねめちゃめちゃ苦労するん
ですそちらに理解するべきがポイントが
あるん
ですそれでおさ様発見したところはこれ
多少教の方々もそこは調べたんだけど答え
見つからないんですね適当な答え出そうん
です1つははこの生きることは希望道路に
行か
ないそれよく分かりますねそれで多少他の
哲学者の宗教哲学者の方々はうんやっぱり
これ神様が決めて神様があのかじ握ってる
んだよと言っちゃうとあなるほど分かり
ました俺の希望通りに行かないの分かり
ますという風に納得いくでもそれはおさ様
は納得いかなかったんですね
なんで誰かが家をねじってるのかとかね
その人の丘の仕事ないんですかねとかね
だって無の生命いるんだから無の生命の命
を管理すると言ったってもとんでもない
こと間がでも戦地線の紙にはなってはいけ
ませんよ大変な地獄なんですよそれ
が我々も加速の面倒見ることでも大変
でしょう
ねこで無償の生命の管理すると言っちゃう
とも話に
なるででおさんそれは認めてないんで誰か
管理するんだと阪さん2つ見つかるんです
ねりんちはなんとしてでもきたるだ
よそれには存よかな
かついと
いうパワーがみんな持ってるんだと生きて
きたいって衝動が
いだから呼吸は楽人でやってるの
に生きることも楽人で起こるはずなん
です本当に楽人なんで生きること
はそう思うほど大な仕事じゃないん
ですだて別に簡単に生きられる
でしょでもご飯がなかったら生けたらそれ
でも自分がお腹がすいて食べるものがなく
て誰がねえばもうこ1日食べてないんだあ
そうじゃちゃじゃこれこれ食べてく何の
ことなく売りますよ
もだから生きることはまそそんなに例えば
農業やることとかねそんなただもう何か
すっちゃえば動作になるんだ
からそんなにあまちゃ殺せる必要ないん
ですねだって何の農業も経済活動もしない
でどせ生きてますから
ねだからそこら辺でこの生きてきたいって
いうこの浴で生命が苦労するんだ
よそれす大事な
ポイントだからお様はこれを発見しました
よ
と全ての生命には単な活いありますよ私は
それはもっと柔らかい日本語にして存
欲for
で訳したんですねもう次のポイント
はちょっとした手違い
で命が壊れるん
ですちょっとした違いで十分
ですシので終わり
ですだからミスってはなれ
ないだから1回のミスで全てパっていう
ことと言うとこれってすごい危険
でしょうこれ我々人間がその問題いろんな
からくりでごまかしでなやってますから
動物世界見ると1回の失敗で
終わりで昆虫がああ気持ちいいな飛んで
みようかなとどんなところで鳥に食べられ
ちゃじゃあ今度は行かないことにしまもう
今度はないん
ですだから視線会見る
と1回の失敗でイが
わるま人間も
ね1回の失敗で大体ありますね運転間違い
1回間違ったらそれで割りとかねまそう
いうケース結構ありますねということは命
ほどもろいものもないんです
ねその
結果くるために祝白味わなくけなくなっ
ちゃう
なくちゃいけないとにかく生きてきなく
ちゃいけ
ないちょっと滑ったら全で
わりそれで死にたくない存在よくあるん
ですねそのからく
で生きることは完全にこの循環であるとお
釈様が心理第1位を形成するんです
この心理は馬鹿にするんじゃないよとこれ
は過去減災未一緒だって心理は心理だよ
かなり自慢し
ますかなり大げさにおさ様自慢し
ます誰にもこれ間違ってると言えませんよ
だからその私はちょこちょこっと阪様が
なんで偉いのかというねなんで我々大阪様
のことそんなに尊敬するのかっていうこと
でまチラチラとこの知恵のポイントをね
まあ私にも先がないんだからあんまりこれ
大で言わないポイントたくさん持ってます
よだからまチラチラいくかその時その時
言おうかなとねだから我々大体聞きて飽き
ちゃっているえ生きることはくであるとカ
はくの
であると
はの会計作であって発生はそのるとて
あんまりなんかそんなにすごい話という風
によく分かる話でしょいうな警視する
でしょうねそうじゃないんですよあれ
すっごい知恵で発見するものなんですだ
から今そのどんな風に様が苦労して発見し
たのかていうねだからそれには天才の中の
天才でないとできることじゃないですから
みんな
て
かねねあみたくもうちょっと気をつけて見
てください
と命は姿勢に流れるならばあんたそんなに
黒い必はないでしょうと
で命は流れるでしょうねとそうじゃなくて
ちょっとした失敗で命が壊れるしかし壊れ
てほしくない生けてきたいという精神的な
あの衝動が入っているその2ある限り
あなた方には救いはないんだよ
と苦しむはめになるんだよそういうわけで
あの話できるだけ早くしますこれ膨大な
テーマなんですけど
ね私たちには暇がないん
です生きることで精一杯
です何やってもま生きるためにやるんです
だウサマルみたいに生きてからやるものは
少ないん
ですで感謝祭は少ないん
ですこれも西洋の感謝祭と似ている感謝
する大阪様
にだからこの我々は感謝祭はわか
で生きるために他全部やってるん
間頑張ってる寝ること
も寝なきだめ
でしょ寝なきゃ健康で生きられませんね
仕事に行けなくなっちゃいますねですから
結局は寝ることすら休みじゃないん
ですそれも仕事なんですだから寝られない
人々は薬飲ん
じゃう私にも聞くんですねなんか瞑想でも
ないんですかねよく寝られるためにとかね
私はベスにないんだからあんたこの名所
やってくださいと5分で寝ます
よで元々アホだからね瞑想できるわけない
でしょ
で私も人に人に言う前に自分でも試せなく
ちゃかんだからね眠気が全くないとはね
大体必ずか1時間ぐらいは寝ますよいくら
なんで
も今日は3時間寝ようと思ったん思って1
時間半ぐらい寝ちゃったんですでまそれは
いいんだけどまプライベートな話だからね
まあ眠がないんだからじゃあ寝ながら名で
もしれば眠がるだってみんな私が知ってる
みんな名しいったと寝てるんだから
ねいてやってみたらどんどん脳が活性化し
ちゃってもういもたってもいられないも
世界のこと宇宙のこと何でもんでも入っ
たりしてて最悪やとだから寝る時私の手段
は寝る時名所する妄想しなさいとだから私
は決まって妄想するん
ですあれやこれやとかなんでくだらない
かっていう思妄想すると知らないうちに寝
ているん
ですまとにかくは言いたかったポイントは
それじゃなくて人間にとって寝ることすら
仕事なん
です生きるためにやる大事な仕事なんです
だからみんな必死で24
時間360
日何ストップ
で休み
なく生きる戦いをしているん
ですそれで今日の
ポイントこれはちょっと英語で言った方が
分かりやすくて論理的でかっこいいんだ
けどねで嫌でしょ英語は
ねじゃあ本日本訳します苦し
てもし誰かが極限に忙しいんだったらその
人に他のことやる暇があります
かabutBU
24havefretimetodo
somethingELyou
haveでこはそんなものになるんですだ
から我々は24時間ものすごい自分が
生きるために忙しいん
です人のこと
構う余裕日はないん
ですそのそは哲学的にまとめるとみんな
わがままけ
でしょわがままっていうのはこれはあの人
をけなすために言ってるあの
クリティカルみんな批判してる単語じゃ
ないんです俺シデなん
ですネチof
Life命
の何でったっ
けちの
すこせんなん
ですあんた生きてるだったらわがまま
ゴキブ君生きてるうんうんじゃあお前
わがまま
命だったらわがままなん
ですだからゴキブ本当わがままで悪いやや
と言権利がないん
です悪い安じゃないんですチョイスは
忙しいんです
他のことを考える余裕ないん
です他人のこと構う余裕ないん
ですだから我々は立派な人間です加速の
面倒見ている子供の面倒見ていると言っ
たてもあれは自分が生きるために一生な
あの部品です
車にね車輪も座席
も車体も一緒
でしょう外にあるペンあれペンキ乗ってる
それも一緒
でしょ生きるために加速回収
です子供がいれば生きることには力入り
ますよし頑張るぞと
だからちょっと犠牲者にならん方がいいん
ですわがままです我がままっていうのは
別所にあの否定的な単語でかってのは皆様
でしょブッダの言葉で我がままていうのは
否定的な単語じゃなくてあれ科学的な事実
だけです
フメ
Selfishだから私の脳がどれぐらい
劣れてるかとあの喋ると分かりますあれ
英語すか歌で理解してあんまり英語使っ
ちゃうと相当脳が行かれてるんですあの昔
はあまり英語の単語言とわなかった
でしょうね元気でしたからね
今もうフレス出てこないんで英語のフレス
言ってしまうまとにかく
でまあ面白いんだからこのフレス覚えたっ
てファンダメンタル
セルフネof
Life命
の法則はそんなもんでだからおわがままや
と指をさすことやめましょうあれは悪行為
です自分がバカであるともうコマーシャル
PRすることですバカでいいんだけどPR
する必要ない
でしょだから人にさってお前わがまま
私そ言いますけども人々にね私のお前ね
それしかできんでしょう
とまそれも事実ですそこ
で我々はあの他の生命と共同作業で生きて
なくちゃいけ
ないひどいん
でしょうこの体の中で23kgぐらい楽し
生命がいるん
ですでないと生きられないん
です私が体重系に乗って私はこれぐらい
体重あり全部自分じゃないんですあの未物
の重さもそっちに入ってるん
です23kgぐらいある
みたいだからが思い方方そんなに困らなく
てもいいんですまもしかするとあの未物の
重さかもしれませんしね昨さんのそれ
言い訳に使いますね私はそんな重くないよ
と
[笑い]
で初行
で困ったことが他生命と共同作業で生きて
なくちかん
ですそれで他の生命わがままで他の生命の
こと構う余裕がないならばそれはどれほど
苦しいことか
とで高校実演で超忙しいお兄ちゃんに中学
生の弟がお兄ちゃんねじゃんお兄ちゃん
これ教えて言っちゃうと怒る
でしょお兄ちゃんは
これお父さんに聞きなさい私は忙しいやと
怒るんでだってあの子はもう受験勉強し
なくちゃかんだ
からだからお兄ちゃんから見る弟はどうせ
頭が悪いでしょまそう決まりです頭いくら
良くてもお兄ちゃんは認めません弟は頭
悪いね俺よりは悪いってまそれて可愛い話
ですけど
まあだからお兄ちゃんが怒れ
ますあるいはお母さんに文句言うあの勉強
に邪魔するんだ
よ弟はあ宿題分からないところ聞いてる
だけその経で考えてくださいお兄ちゃんが
必死で忙しいん
ですこれで食教えてくれと言っちゃうと
迷惑
でしょでも義務的に教えた方がいい
でしょ教えた方がいいと分かってるんだが
けど暇がないん
ですこの精神的な余裕がお兄ちゃんにない
ん
ですこの物語で人生理解しましょう我々は
他の生命の協力があって生きてなくちゃ
いけない生きるっていうことはそういう
共同作業
です他人の助け必ず
もしかし他人が超
忙しいそうすると結果は自分が困るわ困る
わ困るわ困ってどん底に落ちるんです
それも生きることは苦の1つの原因
なだってそれ食う
でしょサじゃない
でしょそういう色々理由があって生ける
ことはだと阪様がま解かれるんです
ねそれでおさ様がもうポイントとして教え
たのは
なんか革命を起こさなくちゃとにかく
何何からな何でも生きてみよではなく
てやめて
やるこんなアホらしい
ことどう見たっても生きることは今現在も
う以外なんでもない明日しわになるかと
いうと違う明日もっと不幸になる
でり死んで輪廻して幸福になるいもっと
不幸に
なるじゃあやめてやるとこの
サイカ悪く循環だから1した方がいい
でしょうにとそれで革命
の革命を教えるんですねそれがおさ様が
悟って教えた教えなんですだ革命の話昨日
も喋りまし
た今日ははベストな
ポイント生命は本来我がままで自分のこと
しかもう他の
こしか興ないではなくて自分のことで精
ぱ余裕はない暇が
ないこのわがままの塊りわがままの塊り
わがままの塊りそれは否定的な単語で
やっぱり我が行っちゃうとどうも否定的
でしょうねこれはしょうがないんですよ
我々悟ってないバカたちがこのセルフィと
いうことはネガティブミーニングで取っ
てるんですあまた語になっちゃったこの
わがままっていうことはこのネガティブ
意味で取ってるんですこれネガティブ
ポジティブじゃないんで地球が丸いという
ことはポジティブあネガティブじゃない
でしょでょ丸いだから
丸いこれはシャニーホール日暮のすごい
悲観的な考えですかねあれ
は
あるいはねポジティブ的な考えですかねで
はなくて事実
とだから生命はえっとえっとわがまま
セルフィということはただの事実
だったらあんた我がままと指さすところも
自分に欠点があるんです自分のシステムに
もう1つ邪魔が入るん
です今も苦労して回転させてるのにもう1
つ道に石が
は入り込むです
もう1個穴が入り込む
んだからさらにでかぼでこぼこで進まなく
ちゃいけなくなっ
ちゃうそれにおさ様は革命的な教を教えた
ん
ですあの
ね一切の生命を意識しんでください
とこれは革命的な教なんですこのささった
バたっ
た一切の生命が幸福でありますようにて
いうフレーズは仏教だけ
です臨愛しなさいとありますよ仲良くし
なさいとどんな文化でもありますでもこの
行動な生命科学はない
でしょジを愛しなさいと言ったっても気を
つけた方がいいんですよやたらに愛しない
方がいいですね私は隣人のは挨拶すすらし
ないんですそれでうまくいってるん
です
でだからこのあんまりやっちゃうとまい
こう道徳でしょう世の中にあるの
はおさ様のこの道徳この
生きとしいけるものが幸でありますようね
ささったすたったこれ自体命的な人類
初めて解かれた言葉なん
ですでそれはこの説明で理解するものなん
ですだから一般説法では言わないポイント
でそれ
も一般的にはまあ教でもえサタスナバント
とま歌ってはいるんだけどねあれは仏教の
パですけどまそれでもいいんじゃないかと
ねで誰でも愛しましょうとね言ってるしね
クリスト教でもねユア教はそうじゃないん
だけどで同じ神ですけど
ねまあまいいんだけどどうせアホだから
みんなまあ
だからこの
なぜ生きとし行けるものが幸せにあり幸せ
でありますよにて念じるのかという
と過去生命
が法則的
に根本的にわがままだからなんです
わがままになるしかないんですそういう罠
にはまってるんです
この苦しい存続
回転存続することは限りない
苦し忙しいん
です我々は十分で倒れちゃう
と他のことやる暇がなくなる
でしょ重房で倒れちゃってあちらこちら
れて
れてもたてかないし動けない
し野球でもやろうと聞いちゃうと意味が
ないでしょうね野球やることできん
キャッチボルでき
ないそれぐらい苦しい状態にいるだから
我々にとっては他生命のこと構う暇がない
んでそれは悪いことじゃなくて法則的に
そうなっているんですだから冷静に生命の
ことを見るとなんか宇宙から地球見るよう
な感じ
で宇宙からも離れて生命を見る
と1個1個我がままで自己回転している
ことを見れる見えるそれもうまくいって
ないことも見える
幸せでありましように
と思うんです思ったら自分の回転が変わる
ん
ですだから自己改革のために自己革命の
ためにやりやすい実践方法っていうのは
生き生きとし行けるものが幸せであります
ようにと今喋った
知恵すって今喋ったブッダのこの心心の
内緒話駄の心はどう働いたのか
とでそういうのは英語で言って方がかっこ
いいと思いますけど
一応おさ様はどうやって物事見ているのか
おさ様はどうやって思を展開させているの
か
と人間やる方法とちょっと違うんですねま
イサンプル見せたんですねそのブッダの
知恵で出た治療方法1個は慈しみ
です私はキリスト教のテキスト調べた
ところ
でナジス
が愛歌ったのかと愛推薦したのかという
とすごい大事な理由書いてるん
です
ま人間が作りたければ私のことを愛する
べきやと神のこと愛するべき神が神
を絶対的にするべきや
とでその訓練として隣人も愛し
ですあれ聞いた読んだだけでネットで聖書
のあれ片っ端しか調べてね昔話ですけど
これもこれ論で成り立ってない
ねジブのりのためてるだから
ねだからやっぱり我がまま
でしょイエスさんもイエスさんの音だと
言ってるあのイホ
さんしょうがないんですよわがまま
ですだからその我がてことはフ事主であっ
て否定的な評価的な単語じゃないんです
そういうわけでなせ慈悲の慈悲ですかと
いう質問にこの理解も達してみてください
で一般的なにはなかなかもう語れない
難しいポイントですそういうのはまあ代表
上仏教とかなんだドランクベス関係なく
心理の世界なん
です科学的な教えなんですだから我々はお
互いにいけしめましょ由はみんな我ま
からかいそうですみんな被害者なん
ですリネ
のみんなあの
例えば被害者って言ま震災とか起きちゃう
と
ねみんな生きてるならば被害者なん
ですだったら心配しするのは当たり前
でしょだから自分自身が被害者で精ぱかも
しれませんだけど覚明的にそれはちょっと
置いておい
て生きとしきるものが幸せでありますよう
にと念じる
思うそれはそれにってこれれないんだから
私は幸でありますようにところから始まる
んですずるいでしょやり方
は私は幸でありませ言ったみな乗るそれで
ちょこじわじわじわと広がってもらうでも
今日教えたこの知恵のポイントがあった方
がより一層レベル高い慈悲の瞑想できると
思いますそういう偉大なる知恵で我々にシ
だ
から
ののりで開は盛大にお祝いたしますだから
皆様にもブッダの偉大なる幸福偉大なる
孤独の力で幸福でありますようにシであり
ますように早く心きらからになって下に
達することができますようにと願いたし
まして終了しますありがとうござい
ますこれからえ1時間えは大場仏教のお坊
様のはいお時間でござい
ますありがとうございました長老
ありがとうございますえ長老のおかげで私
の体重は75kmという半分のね半分の
体重で申請していいというようなお話でし
たので私75kgになりますね
775km美物ですえそういうわけで今日
今度からは大丈夫今の方の話になり
ます
124そう
ですえバタバタしながらに進めてくか
話し合いましたまずはお前から行ってこい
ということでえっと私とお釈迦様の教え
みたいなところから話させていただきます
よろしくお願いし
ますえ私はあのこのお釈迦様の教えに
出会う前は参学修行とか滝に打たれる修行
っていうのをやりまくってました滝には
おそらく1000回ぐらい打たれたと思い
ますでそれから3年間ほど大峰さんの奥書
修行というね日本で唯一女性が登る山が
あるんですけど大峰さんという山なんです
けどねそこの案内にするまであの山岳修業
もうちょっと痩せてましたからねあの美
生物も少なかったし
えそこの山岳資業の案内人なんかをしてい
ました四国変ってねあのあのお四国をね
歩いて回る資業もありますけどそんなのも
2週半ぐらい歩いて野宿しながら修行して
ました何して山の中にしか仏教がないと
思ってたんですねでえ山の中で修行する
ことが教だってすごく信じ込んでましたの
でね
え滝人も打たれ滝なんかはね夏場なんか
台風の後はねあの滝も日間朝昼番入るって
決めて修行するのであの台風の後も入ら
なきゃいけないですね台風って言ったら
もうどえい水量ですからこれひょっとし
たら俺でも流されるかもしれへんなみたい
なねそんなあのヒヤヒヤしない滝に打た
れる修行なんかもしていきましたそれで
まあ1000回ぐらい打たれて修行した時
にやっぱ不動明が見えるようになるんです
ねあの滝の中でね拝んでたらね不動明さん
がねま迎えにあの立ってらっしゃるのが
見えるようになるんですよでこれは俺も
悟ったかもしれんなっていうよなねそんな
あの感じにもなるんですけどそれでもね
やっぱりまだなんか悟れてないなっていう
のはするんです気がしてたんですねもお不
動産が見えたとしてもじゃあ私のことを
本当に守ってくれるのかって言ったらよく
わからんのです
ねでま希望した時にお不動産みたいのが
見えるようになったりもするんだ
けどいつも守ってもらうためには例えば
電車の中の前から何両目に乗った方がいい
のかとか聞かなきゃいけないのかなとかね
あのトイレはま奥から何番目のトイレに
入った方が安全なのかとかそんなくだらん
ことまで聞く必ことにになっちゃいます
からねものすごく依存してましたからねだ
からそれもなんか違うなというのがあった
んですねそれで滝業もあのま000回
ぐらいでちょっとやめちゃったんですま
あのお不動産見えたけどなんかされてな
いっていう気がしたんですそれでその後
大峰さんのその奥書修行という修行に入り
ましてまそれも3年間ぐらいやりましたえ
そうしましたらねもう一歩一歩ものすごい
丁寧に歩くんですねま1200mに山々を
ねずとあの何日間もかけてね歩いていくの
があの大峰さんの奥修行という修行なん
ですけどそういう修行しますとねその
一歩一歩丁寧に歩かないと足くじいた時点
でも修行が終わりちゃうんですねまた
浮き石とか踏んで下に置ことしたら他の
仲間が怪我するっていうのもありますので
ものすごく丁寧にぷい歩くようになるん
です
よそれでねあの岳業やりまくっててふと
気づいたんですしてる時はすごい心綺麗だ
ぞ
とだけど終わって実生活に戻ってくると
また心が汚れるんですねまた欲が出るし
怒りは出るしなんか不思議だったんですね
でもまたそれでちょっとおかしちょっと
自分の心がおかしいなと思ったらまた山岳
収用に行くそうするとまたやっぱり綺麗に
なるんですよ女性がいない山なので男
ばっかりの世界ですからね欲が出ない
でしょで欲が完全にコントロールでできる
しま怒りもねお互いに修行仲間だから大切
にするしね怒りもコントロールできるし
なんか修行の山に入ると心が清らかになる
けど降りてくると里に降りるとやっぱり
怒りもよくも出てきちゃうっていうそう
いうことを繰り返して3
年間やりましたそれでもなんかねその滝の
時も不動産見えるようになったけどなんか
悟れてないなっていうのがあったしその
山岳資業散々3年間やったけどそれでも
やっぱり悟れてないなっていう気がしてた
んですよでもあの欲とか怒りとかを
コントロールするのには滝に打たれると
もう真剣真面目にやるのであるいは山岳
修行するのも真剣真面目にするので欲とか
怒りとかのコントロールはかなりできるん
ですねだからこれは悟へのその近道だと
思ってましただからこもうあとねもうこの
修行の若い男が修行するにはこの滝の修行
とあの山岳修行をさえしていれば心きらに
することができるのでこれが私はね修行な
のではないかなと思ってたんですねそれだ
けど女性と若いお子さんとそれから落とさ
れた方この方たちができませんね滝なんか
に打たれたら自存放され死んじゃったりし
ちゃいますからねあるいは山岳資業ももう
本当にヘロヘロになるまで歩き続けます
からね朝あのま3時ぐらいに起きてねえ夜
の夕方の6時ぐらいまで歩き続けるってい
ような修行がしますのでそ落とされた方も
できないんですねだからこの子供と落とし
された方と女性ができる修行っていうのが
何かないかなと思って初めて須原長老の
勉強会に参加させてもらったんですもう
それはね奪うためでしたもうその自分の
修行としては滝の修行と山岳修行であると
でそのお年寄りとお子さんと女性のための
修行方法を何かもらえたらこれで全人類が
この修行をすれば心清らかになれるという
そういう確信があったのでそれでスサ長老
のあの初心者瞑想指導に参加させて
いただいたんですねで
あのそうしましたらね
あのここで歩くだけで右足上げる箱を
下ろす左足上げる箱下ろすて歩くだけで
めちゃくちゃ真剣に歩くんだから山の中
歩いてると一緒の気合いいります
よただボケット右足あげる運ぶ下ろす左足
あげる運ぶおろすとかそれであったらダメ
だけどもう真剣にやるんですよ滝に打た
れる時に自分も真剣にやったよう
に山岳修行する時に浮き足浮き石に足を
乗っけないようにものすごい丁寧に歩く
ように真剣に右足上げる箱す左足上げる
ほす歩い
たらそここでもう欲が出ないんですよ
ね怒りも憎しみも嫉妬もなくなっちゃうん
ですよそこ真剣にやるっていうとこが
大きなポイントですけど
ね滝に打たれる必要もなければ山岳使用
する必要もないんです
よここででき
ますで座る瞑想の時も例えばストップ
モションの時も真剣真面目にやってみて
ください1分間ストップモーションして
実況中継してみたら座っています感じて
ます座ってます感じてまて言ってみたら
怒りが生まれませんね嫉妬も憎しみも欲も
生まれないです
ねだからそれ考えるとわざわざ滝に打た
れる命がけの滝に打たれる修行しなくても
いいし命がけの三岳しよで熊にあの出会う
ことだってありますからね我々の山岳仕
って言ったら熊に出会って頭はかれてね耳
ぴょんって飛んじゃったような人だってい
ますからねだからそこまでの命かける修行
をする必要もないんです真剣真面目にやれ
ばと言ってもねま我々人間だからあの私も
座る瞑想始めてま23分で寝てます
ね寝てるんだけどもすぐ気づいたら今度腕
手あげる下ろすていう修行に変えてみたり
もう1回あの最初からやり直してみたり魔
研究だけはあるん
ですまずあの妻長老の推に出会ったのが
33歳ぐらいの時でしたか
ねそれでもうここのここでね安全なここで
真剣にやればよくもいかれもコントロール
できるんだってことを知ってそれでま
ずっとお釈迦様の教えと親しくさせて
いただいてきましたでまあのちょっとね
あの
ものすごくなんて言うのかなお釈迦様の教
がもうすごくこれがすごいと思っても理解
できたと思っちゃったもんだからそれから
ついこの間までかなりの間約20年間
サボりにサボってきましたあのねなんかね
ま長老40歳の頃には長老の推薦であの
朝日カルチャーセンターで初心者指導とか
しなさいて言って声かけていただいたから
初心者瞑想の指導なんかもさせてもらっ
たりしたもんだからちょっとうちゃったん
ですねちょっと俺はできるなっていう風に
思っちゃったんですよそうするとも完璧な
生気になります
ね怠けちゃうんです俺はちょっとできてる
俺はちょっと仏教分かってるって思っ
ちゃってたんですいや20年間かかりまし
たよでこの間の
あのえっとゴールデンウィークの時に須原
長老の北トピアさんでのね瞑想合宿の時に
自分の宿題は自分でしろよっていうお言葉
があったんですねで私ね自分のこの瞑
例えば座る瞑想するとすぐ寝るせがあ
るっていうのは自分で分かってたんです
けどちょっと右頂点になってたからま俺は
いいだろうと思ってたんですよま俺は仏教
分かってるからま許されるだろうと思って
ましたけどなんかちょこっとと喉に骨が
引っかかってるような感じだったん
ですで長老がね自分の宿題自分でしろよと
自分の人生の宿題ぐらい自分でしろよって
いうお話された時にこれはやばい
ともう今日から始めて自分の宿題自分で
やらなきゃあかんなと思って1日歩く瞑想
立つ瞑想座る瞑想ってねワンサイクル回す
ように努始めましたまだ3日間ぐらいです
からね3日坊主だけどあの3日間ぐらいは
ねあのタメアクメ座るメってあの1日1回
はねワンサイクル回すように始めました
そんなわけで私もね
あのそういう意味では初心の修行者です
えこれからまだまだ修行せないかん立場
ですけれども負ける気はしないんです負け
たくはないんです自分の宿題は自分でやり
たいんですだから眠っちゃっても眠っ
ちゃったらダメだけどね失敗修行失敗だ
けどそれでも負けませんよ手上げたり
下ろしたりしてもう1回呼吸整えてもう1
回姿勢整えてもう1回始める30分間と
いう時間は
やる何回寝たとしてももう1回起きてもう
1回最初から始めてもう1回
やるこの魔剣気だけはあの私は持ち続け
たいなと思っていますで私はないでしょ
仏教の教えではね私はない因果法則でしょ
あるのは因果法則私はないあるのは因果
法則だから私負けてもいいんですよ
ちょっとぐらいちょっとぐらいていうか
負けはしますけどね眠っちゃったらそれも
それで仕方なでしょだけど負けないんです
いじでも勝ってやろうという気でおります
というわけで私も皆さんと一緒のねあの
これからまだまだ仕業やっていかなきゃ
いけない立場の人間です是非よろしくして
いただけたらありがたいなと思いますえ
今日は皆さんお集まりいただきまして
ありがとうございました
ちょっと私はあのこちら方がいいので
こちらの方であのお話しさせていただき
たいと思うんですけどもえっと木さんの方
からですねえ3分間あのおさ様と私しって
いう台でま話せっていう風にま言われまし
てえちょっと色々考えてきたんですけども
ま考えたっていうよりはですねえま大阪様
とのまえま出会いっていうかですねまそう
いったことをちょっとお話ししたいと思う
んですけども私はあの前週の僧侶でえまえ
道場にねま少しだけ行きましてそれでま
ちょっと縁があってですねま埼玉県のあの
お寺の方のま住職になったんですねま住職
になる時にはですね普通はなんかあの試験
みたいなのがあるんですよ水字式って言っ
てまちょっと法あのえ述べるっていうか
ですねこの教えを述べるっていうか
まそれでまえ修行が未熟だったんですけど
もまこういうことかなってことま話しまし
てままその式自体もま結構形式的なところ
もあるのでねまま元々もそ住職にな
るってのも決まってますからねまそれは
そのままで言ったんですけどもま私がまあ
ま元々このえ仏道に入った理由が
えこのま色々私あの他あの仕事したこと
あるんですねあの出血する前にそれでま
色々まえま素質があまりま良くなかったの
かもしれないですけどもやっぱり仕事も
なんかあんまりうまくいかないしま
いろんなことでま
えま生きててまいろんな苦労してま生きて
いっても結局死ぬんだろうと思ってですね
えそれでまでもせっかく
そのま死にたかったんですけどもま
せっかくま生まれてきたんだだしま両親の
ま世話になってるわけですよねだからあの
まなんとかそのま有効にま生きられる方法
はないかなっていう風にま考えたんですね
それであの他の宗教にも行ってった言って
ましたえまそのことはちょっと今日は話し
ませんけどもそれでまあのえま心理が
分からないと生き方が分からないと思った
んですよ心理が分からないと
真理が分からないで生きた生きてて生きて
たらですね本当にさっきあの大和であった
ようにま苦ですよねドッカですよねただ
生きてるわけですからそれで死んでいく
わけですよねまはっきり言ってま無駄な
わけですよねだから心理が分からなければ
生き方が分から
ない心理が分かれば生き方が分かるわけ
ですよねそれに沿って生きればいいわけ
ですからそれでもってまあの色々
その道を探してま出血したんですけどもま
道場に行っても
あの何やってんのかなって感じだったわけ
ですよねそれでもってまやる気もなくなっ
てきても早々にも道場出てしまったわけで
それでまま住職になってでも住職になって
もですねずっとそのモヤモヤしてるわけ
ですよねでモヤモヤしてたんですがあの実
はこの刑する前にはす先生のまごを読んで
ましてそれはあの人生はゲームですって
いう著書だったんですよそれでまそこの
内容がですねあのお釈迦様の言った教に
スーっとなんかストレートな教えだったん
ですねでこの日本の仏教はいろんなその
教えがあってま田様にお願あの委ねるば
いいとかいう教えとかですねそれから観音
様の力を頼めばいいとかですねまそういっ
た教えがあるんだけどもお釈迦様は努力
しろって言ってわけですよごちゃごちゃに
なっててもさっぱりわかんなかったんです
よねでもお釈迦様のその教えの中にはその
無名っていうのが原因だっっていう風にま
おっしゃられたわけですそれでもってです
ねあのさっきあの木瀬さんがおっしゃった
前はもう結構小さいホールであのえ瞑想
指導とか
えなんかあのなん言うですか質問の
受け答えとか先生がされてされてまして
もって私はま自分は僧侶だったんですけど
はっきり言ってあの自分があの他の宗派の
僧侶がですね他あの宗派のあの先生に質問
するってのとてもなんか恥ずかしかったん
ですけども私はとにかく心理が知りたいっ
てのがあったんで先生にですねあの無名
っていうのはどういうことですかっていう
の質問してみたんですよ
そしたらちょっとあの記憶がちょっと
定まっもう定かじゃないんですがえっと
です
ね私たちにとってご飯って言え
ば白いあのご飯お茶碗の上にあの乗ってる
ご飯のことを思い浮かべんだけども牛だっ
たらご飯は草だっていう風におっしゃられ
たんですね確か
で私たちはご飯を見て美味しそうとかです
ねまこのよだれが出たりですねま気持ちが
出てくるんですけども牛は草を見ると
美味しそうと思う
わけで私たちが草を見る
とつまんないもんですよねで牛がご飯を
見るとつまんないもんですまそういったお
話されたんですけどその時ですねすごい
よくわかったんですよ無名っていうのが
え私たちのこの同じもの見てんのに認識の
世界に閉じ込められてそん中で心が
ぐるぐる回ってんだと思ったんですよねご
ぐるぐる待って牛は牛の
世界私は私の
世界とってもなんかわがままな感じですよ
ねね牛牛さんご飯くれません
そしたら牛さんが草を来る私そんなも食べ
られませんつったらとてもなんかわがまま
ですよねだそん時にすごくそのこれじゃあ
心は自分の世界の中で回っちゃうよと思っ
てこれじゃあ輪廻しちゃうよなと思ったん
ですよねそそれでその時ですねあの本当に
なんかこれが無かと思って
えすごくなんか嬉しかったんですよ
それがなんか私のお釈迦様との出会いでえ
なんて言うんですか今までそれまではなん
かなんか教えがこの遠くにあったんですよ
ねでも今は無名に生きてる自分が色々ま
こう改造度を上げましてね穴は綺麗かなっ
てづ近づいてみる
となんか綺麗じゃないみたいな感じで改造
度を上げてま修行するとねビッパサナでね
えそういったことでこの道にままお釈迦様
が入らせてくれてま入らせてくれた玄関
ですよね奥深い感え玄関入っていそして
いろんな深いいろんなことを仏法をなんか
ま総合的に学ぶことができてですねあ
お釈迦様の教え
はうちのお寺にもちょっと飾ったんです
けどあの推奨級ってあるじゃないですか
推奨級あのこのまん丸いあの何の
えでこぼこもない推奨級おしざの教え
は足すこともできない足したらびになっ
ちゃうんです引いたら穴が開いちゃうん
ですよ託すこともできなくて引くことも
できない完全な完全無欠な教えなんだなっ
ていう風になんかま私は思いましてえ本当
にお釈迦様がいらっしゃらかったらえ
そしてその
え看にですね玄関に導き入れていただき
ました先生スマサイル先生には本当にま
ありがたいありがたいなと思ってま引いて
はですねサガが続いてるからこういうこと
になってんですよちゃんとサガが保たれて
いるからなんですねサガのえ率とかですね
まリですねが乱れてくるとなんか結果が
ですねあのまひどいことになりますよねま
あの見る皆さんも見ることができると思い
ますけども率が保たれているんで法が
伝わっていくんですねだから今後もあの
参画がですねこうやって末長くまたえ続い
ていっていただければなという風にえ願い
ましてえ私のお話はこれで以上とさせて
いただきますどうもありがとうございまし
た
休憩時間
です
あのお二方からねあの派なお話いただき
ましてすごいなとあの常に電話で喋ったり
ね直接会って喋ったりしてるんですけれど
も改めてこうやって聞くとすごく
ありがたいなと思って善友っていう言葉を
やっぱり思い出しますよ皆様方もそれぞれ
それぞれの人生の中でご家族ご親族え友人
同級生色々な方々と関わり合って生きてる
と思いますけれどもまそれがあの現場の
リアルっていうやつだと思いますあの
して想像していろんなことをま妄想でも
いいんですけれどもこうあればいいああ
なったらいいなとかあれは嫌だななんて
いう風に考えてる人生でありますけれども
でもそういうところでえ理想通りっていう
のを追い求めてしまいすぎるとなんとなく
足元がねほろになったりするようなことは
ないですかねえ今1番大事なねあの家族と
か友達とか今まさしく過ごしているこの
時間を
妄想の世界の中だけで過ごしてしまうと
なんかもったいないような気がするんです
よ私はあの1年に1度皆様方と会うって
いうのをものすごく楽しみにして新幹線に
乗ってやってくるんですけれどもあの何か
あったら来れないですよね直前に何か大事
があったらこっちまで東京まで出てくる
こともできないしえそして途中で帰らなく
ちゃいけないかもしれないでも帰らなく
ちゃいけない時にえすぐ帰れるかと言っ
たらなかなか新幹線の本数がとかねえそう
いうないろんな障害をちょっと思ったり
するんですねだからこそこの場この瞬間
このウサカの食材というのがものすごく
個人的には大事に大事に思っておりますえ
木下さんがね
あのま最初に木下さんの話をいじらなきゃ
いけないみたいなルールになってるんです
かねあのうちのお寺に来てあのお汁粉16
杯ぐらい食べましてですねえ全人の大記録
を立てたわけですけれどもまそれの結果が
これですね
えだからやっぱり食辛坊ですねはい簡単に
言うとでも可愛らしいですよえそうやって
たくさんたくさんおじいちゃんとかおばあ
ちゃん来てる田舎の包容の中ですごい
たくさん食べてくれるお寺さんが来たよと
一生残るでしょあのお寺さん面白かったね
とものすごい食べたよねってそしてあの
笑顔でしょだからそういう風なものを
やっぱりたくさん与えてくださってえ山形
県なんですけどもそこまで来てそして帰っ
てえそれでもあのお寺さん元気あの寺さん
もう1回呼んでよみたいな話になっていく
わけですね縁がまできたとでそういう風に
え住原長老のことを知ってそしてここにえ
たどり着くまで24年ぐらい今2024年
ぐらいですかねえ2000年ぐらいに
初めて民勝者にあの全然分からなくてそれ
でもお寺であろうということで訪ねていっ
たら何かがあるはずだからぐらいの知識
ですよそれで来てまだゴータ勝者が内装
終わってなかったですね全然知らなかった
ですけどでそしてえ壁もちゃんとまだ塗っ
てないような状態でやってきて今日何も
ありませんよって言われてえって言って
帰ったっていうあのこれが1番最初なん
ですけどねえその後予定表を渡されてえ
長老の瞑想会はこういうとでやってますよ
長老の拠点解説はこういうとこでやって
ますよだから私としてはあ千駄ヶ谷区民
会館というところでえ瞑想会をやっておっ
たのでえそれに行きやすかったんですね
曜日がちょっと出れたというえそれで仙田
区民会館というところが私の1番の原体権
としてありましてでそれで長老に須原長老
に色々なことを教わりましてあ素晴らしい
なと思ってで東京までえ来てその日帰りと
かできなかったりする場合ありますねあの
新幹線の最終が遅いわけですからあ早い
わけですからえそれで止まらなきゃいけ
ないで止まるちてもなかなかあの選べない
ですよもう安くていい加減なところでも
止まらなきゃいけないとでもねずっと夜中
中そんなそんじそこらで過ごすわけにも
いかないからというんでで泊まったらお
風呂があってま風呂つきのえ昔のビジネス
ホテルみたいなんですかね共同のお風呂な
んですよで風呂がついてだけいいなと思っ
てお風呂見たらですねなんとなく家庭のお
風呂ぐらいの湯がありまして洗場が3箇所
めちゃめちゃ狭かったんですでもまいいや
と思ってでスリッパが置いてあったらま誰
かが入ってるからこれ入りづらいなと思っ
てない時ない時なかなかねあのスリッパが
いつもあったんでも2人入ってるなって
分かったんですけども私入ったんですよま
3人目ですからねまアイバぐらいはる
だろうとでえその時はね帰りじゃなくて
こっち来た時なんですけどあの包容に出席
しなきゃいけないから髪の毛剃ろうかなと
思ったんですお風呂で髪剃持ってで入っ
てったら全身入れ墨の2人がいたんですよ
でまあまあでもましゃあないですよねで
すいませんつって入ってってでこっち
髪の毛剃ってたんですよそしたら
ものすごく元気なね若者がガンガンガンと
か言ってお風呂にやってきてものすごい
元気にうらみたいな感じで塔を開けたん
ですそしたら入れ墨の2人と1人頭剃っ
てるわけですからね地獄のようなお風呂を
見たわです彼はで最初ものすごい乱暴に
入ってきたんですけどああみたいな感じで
そしたらねそれ見た瞬間にまこっちも見る
でしょあんまり乱暴に入ってくるからわっ
て全員が見たと思うんですけどものすごく
丁寧に扉を閉めて足音1つ立てずに
ゆっくりと帰っていった
ん人間の心が瞬間的に変わったところを見
たんですねだから大丈夫です皆様方も
変われ
ます地獄のようなお風呂でしたねだから
やっぱりこの世界に生きるということは私
は須原長老の瞑想会仙田ヶ組会館に行って
たからそういうお話も聞きえそしてスロー
モーションとか色々右足左足
座る瞑想立つ瞑想歩く瞑想えそれぞれ
それぞれのことを教えていただいたから
そういう場面にあってもああこれはこう
いうことなんだろうなとそしてその若者が
もし何らかのそういう知識を持ってたら
何かそっから継続して修行になった
でしょうでもそうではないと思いますよ
そうではないと思うんですけれども
おそらくああ世の中には自分自身がいかに
乱暴に行っても通らないことがあるんだな
ていう人生のとなったと思いますんで
ちょっと大人しく生きたかもしれませんね
その後まそういうようなことでね私たちの
心っていうのは瞬間瞬間変化消滅し続ける
そして変わり続けるもう変わるんだったら
良き方向に変わりましょうよ悪い方向悪い
方向へと進んで行きがちなんですけれども
ね落ち込んだり悩んだり苦しんだりでも
私たちは教えていただいたお釈迦様の知恵
のその光えその方向に明るいとろが向かう
方向でしょ暗いところが向かっちゃダメな
方向でしょだったら私たちはその今日の
上沢の祝福の法よえこうやってえ少しお
祭りだから楽しくやってくれよって木下尚
に言われたんでえちょっと面白い話も
しようかなと思って手で来たんですけども
まあまああのさっきの話を聞いてねえ
ちょっと思い出したんでえそんな話をし
ましたえどうか皆様方が本日この場にいて
そしてしてえそして心っていうものが色々
先版下変わっていき移り変わりしたと思う
んですけれどもえそれは素晴らしい体験を
したと思いますよそのことを胸にまた次の
一方明日から明後日からそして自分自身の
身の回りの方々にえやっぱり向ける気持ち
も少しえ整った状態で生きてまいりたい
なっていうようなことを思っていただけ
たらと思いますよ本日はどうもありがとう
ございました幸せでありますように
皆さんこんにちは市川と申しますえっと
高野さん信言州でえっと私はあの木下さん
のあの後全部後輩ですね大学も後輩でえ
その小屋さんの先週学院っていう防災妖精
学校も後輩でえ初めて入った会社の上司も
木下さんのお父さんだったっていうところ
でですねあのここのテラバーダーさんと
あのご縁ができましたで私とお釈迦さんと
いうテーマでえっと3分ぐらいという話な
んですがえっと私が所属していたあの小屋
さん信言集っていうのはあの空海さんが
開いたえ中国から持ってきたいわゆる北電
仏教の中の1つの密教っていうものを持っ
てきてましてでイメージとしてはあの
マンダラとかあのそういったものが大きい
と思いますで先ほど木下さんからお話が
あったあの藤さんとかですねえっと観音
さんとかああいうあのいわゆる中心に大日
如来がいて周りにその仏さんたちがいるま
ヒーローが集待ってる図鑑みたいなそう
いうものを祭っているあの集配になります
でえっとそこであのまず防災要請学校の中
でえ授業があるんですがその授業の中でえ
結構名物なあの先生がいらっしゃいまして
え京都
大学でえ出身のえ研究をしていてそのまま
小屋さん大学に来てえ小屋さ大学で教えて
え仏教学を教えてる方なんですねでえっと
密教は
あの信言と言ってあのサンスクリット語
ここはあのパーリ語ですけれども
サンスクリット語をあのもあの真実の言葉
だとしてあの話したりしていますえっと
そのサンスクリット語を研究しているあの
先生がですねお釈迦さんはこういうこと
言ったんだていうようなお話がありました
で元々その観音さんがいるとかですですね
藤さんがいるっていう前提であの私は生き
てきましてま25年ぐらい前なんですけど
大学を休学してですね1年間あのその防犯
妖精学校に入りますもちろん今髪生やし
ちゃってますけど当時はあの紙沿ってです
ねえっとこの同じ同じパターンでやって
ましたでえっとそこでまちなみにあの某
さんはあれ
皆さんあの紙そりはジレットですよね
やっぱりなんか坊山ごしあのシックだと歯
がかけちゃったり詰まっちゃったりするの
でジレットっていうのはまちょっとあの
アックですかじゃあんまり毛がないの
なかったのかあすませんちそうですよね
はいあの大体あの若いとですねどんどん毛
が生えてきてですねすぐボロボロになっ
ちゃうのであのそのジレットを使ってって
いうそんなような感だったんですけどもで
えっと80人入って卒業したのが60人
みたいな感じで大体スマホとか電荷製品の
中から急にこういうかっこいいなて平安
時代のあのね生活様式で歩く方もですね
あの角を取りなさいっていう言い方をする
んですが基本的にはすり足でこうやって
歩いてですね角の時は角の90°を当てて
こう曲がるとこういう歩き方をしなさいと
まこれ全然今考えると歩きの瞑想でもなん
でもなくて単にあの日本の歩き方っていう
だけの話なんですがまそういうものを
叩き込まれてですねあのなかなかその常識
で合わない場合はあの脱落していくって
いうだから80何人入って23割脱落です
ので60人ぐらいが卒業するっていうな
あの学校になりますでその中でその名物の
京都大学出身のあの小屋山大学の教授が
ですですねお釈迦さんはまず
あの神仏なんかいないって言って当時
立ち上げたんだという話をしたんですね
ええみたいな当時はそのある意味あの企業
で言うとベンチャー企業なので何をその
理念というかポリシーにしてバーンて
突き上げるかというとこでその話をされて
ましたえ神仏いないのじゃどうしたいいん
ですかみたいなそんな他を寄りとするなと
自らを寄りとせいっていうことま今でいう
あのちょの話で言うと自透明法透明って
いうお話だったと思いますでかなり衝撃を
受けましてであじゃどうしたらそれをそ
そのそ自らを寄りとことしてって言って
じゃどうしたらいいんですかって話でそう
するとあのサンスクリット語ではあの
パーリ語でもあるのかもしれないですけど
Rかっていう言葉があってえ甘く見るんだ
と1つの物事に囚われないであらゆる場面
が見なさいっていうまあ今で言うと証券
っていうことだと思いますがそのあの言葉
をですね聞きしてああという風に衝撃が
降りましたでえその後結局その密教の行者
っていうのはそのユガ業っていうであの
ヨガ今でいうヨガというかま瞑想しなさ
いっていういうことを言うんですがそれと
同時にこういう偶像崇拝やをするなと
そんなもはいないんだっていう前提で修行
しなさいっていうことを言われてですね
かなり一般的な常識と違うなと思った
ところが1つの衝撃ポイントでしたで
えっと次にですね私はあの仕事をしており
ましてえあ仕事っていうのは普通に会社
入って仕事をしたんですが初めて入った
会社がその木さんの上あ木さんのお父さん
がいらっしゃる会社でえっとそこあ木さん
のお父さんは
あの当時役員もやれてたんかわかんない
ですけどもそこの会社はですね
え経営研究所をやっておりましていわゆる
上場企業のあの社長になるような方の幹部
研修をやっている会社でしたでえっとそこ
であのそこの卒業生があの今で言うとJR
の社長とかIBM日本IBMの社長とか
マイクロソフトの社長とかそういう方が
あのいらあの排出するようなあの期間だっ
たんですけどもなんかいかにも私はそこに
いただけなので別に私がそこすごいやっ
てるわけではないですけどもそういうよう
な会社ででそこで
あの全さんがあの歩きの瞑想の講座をされ
てたんですねその多分40歳以降の活動の
中だったとものでそれでえちょろと同じ
ようなお話をあのされててそこが2番目の
衝撃でしたね生き物の定義は何かとか人間
は歩いているうんこの袋だとかね
え無茶言うなと思ってたんですけどもま
そこからあのいかちゃん次の瞑想したら
教本あげるよとか言われて私やっぱり
そうそういうの飢えてますので必死であの
100日間じゃ時の瞑想したらあのパリゴ
拠点あげようかなとかそれで最初ちかされ
てですね必死であのやってましたそれ15
年ぐらい前ですかねでそれでゲットして
から
あのいまいちよくわかんなかったんですよ
ねずとそこから10年ぐらいわかなかった
んですけどでその後もえっと今は自主的に
その経営者の人とかが修行の場の勉強会で
私が一緒にあのお手伝いでさせていただけ
てるんですけども
私はあのその全さんから学んだ慈悲の瞑想
か長老から学んだ慈悲の瞑想のやり方を
その湯場でお伝えしてたですねその経営者
の方の方がすごい慈悲状態になっちゃって
ですねあのもうなんか
大なんか大黒さみたいな父福士みたいな顔
されるようになっちゃなってきちゃったん
ですねもうニコニコのごいですねいみの
状況はっていう風にあのお伝えしたらです
ねあ実はちさんあの
この時の瞑想やってて不思議なことが
起きるんですよっていう話
をしてきたんですねでどんな話なのかって
いうとあのその方
運送会社のあの社長さんでえっと朝4時と
か5時とかに車に乗ることがあるそうなん
ですねでえっと朝どんなに忙しくてもあの
絶対やる毎日1回はやるっていうつもりで
自の瞑想をやってるそうなんですねでどれ
ぐらいその方が忙しいかって言うと繁忙機
は忙しすぎてあの自分がってる
iPhoneのロックナンバーのあのパス
コードを解除するあれが分かんなくなった
どんだけ忙しいのかって思うんですけど
あれ繰り返ししすぎるとデータ飛んじゃう
らしいんですよバックアップ取ってなくて
飛んじゃいましたとかていうような話はさ
れてたんですけどそれぐらい忙しくても
時期の瞑想だけをやってたそうなんですね
でえっとそうするとですねあの朝4時とか
5時のね薄暗い中にも関わらずジギの瞑想
してきたしてたらトントントンてノックし
てくる人がいるんですねえんですかって
やったらバーって開けたら道教てください
とか言って言ってくるかもうホラーですよ
ねすごい怖かったんですって言って今度
あのその運送会社なんでちょっとあのお客
さんも入れるような状態になってるらしい
んですけどそこのあのねあの仕事場のとこ
で行ったら今度仕事場にわざわざあの道
教えてくださいって来る人が来たですて
もうみんな半分きすぎそのロックナンバー
忘れるぐらい忙しい中でもやっぱそういう
なかもう助けを求める人が来るんだみたい
な話をされててですねああこの慈しみの
状態を持つとかそういう状態がある程度
行くと自然と向こう側からあのなんか助け
てっていうのがが来るんだなっていうのが
あのすごく学びになりまして
えっとそでえ例えばなから皆さんはもう
かなり日本の中でも最も慈悲の瞑想やっ
てる割合がここ多分高いとは思うんです
けども車とかにでコンコンはされないと
思うんですがあの電車乗ってねなんか急に
なんか私んとこだけお年寄が来るなとか
妊婦さん来るなと思ったらあなたのあの時
の状態がすごく上がってるという風に思っ
ていただければすごくあのあよしよし修業
してるなっていう風に思えんじゃないかな
と思いますで同時に私もその慈しみの
気持ちを持ってですね毎日過ごしたいなと
思っておりますのでま一緒にあの頑張って
いきましょう以上ですありがとうござい
ました
はい私
は平たな長老があれおられないあおられ
ますね若木寺の勇志平和な長老がスピーチ
されたので私も年置いた大場坊主で頑張ら
なければならないと思ってこれは繁かち
ですけども今日はあのもう年ですからね
話す内容忘れちゃいかんと思って
メモをたっぷりと用意してきましてこれが
あれば絶対話す内容忘れないぞとすごく
安心しましたじゃどうもありがとうござい
まし
たすいませんねあのせっかくのお祝いの日
なのにあの私の話でお耳よしになるかも
しれませんけどあのまあ日本の大場の坊さ
の物の見方というものもちょっとま知って
おいてもらおうかなということで今日
テーマでいいたのがお釈迦様と私なんです
けれどもあの私にとってはあの実はあの私
一応仏教学者ということになってまして
あの広島大学の客員教授というのをま今6
年目なんですけどね70になるぐらいまで
やらせていただけるんじゃないかという風
には思ってるんですけれどもま
そんなこんなで仏教学者という風に名乗っ
ておりますのでにとってお釈迦様って言っ
たら接する
あの手がかりはテキストなんです
ね経の中に開立の中にお釈迦さの言葉が
ありますからこれがまお釈迦様が実際に
語られた言葉だよとそれをま学んでいれば
お釈迦様の教えに触れられるんじゃないか
なということで結構ま真剣にやっている
つもりなんです
でところが仏教学者と名乗りたいんです
けれども仏教学だけなんか変だなっていう
のはもう皆様もお気づきかもしれません
けれどもあの大きなパラドックスがあり
まして例えばあの医学だったらねあの医学
部出たような人があの現場のお医者になっ
てもいいんだけどちょっと研究の道に
進もうかなということで大学とか研究所と
かに残ってああこういう病気が出てきたら
こういう風な薬がいるなとかこういう風な
ところに病気が出てきたらこういう治療法
でないといかんなとか色々ま研究する人が
いるんですね医学者がいるんですね医学部
の教授とかねそういう人たちがま薬学とか
いろんなものとチーム組んで新しい道を
何か見つけておこれこそというところでま
実験もやりますけどねそれで現場に持って
いくんですね現場の技術のあるお医者さん
にこういう風な治療法でやってみてくれ
ませんかとお医者はお医者で患者さんが
苦しんでるからこれなんとか助けてあげ
なくちゃいけないけど今まで何にも方法
なかったところにあこういう道具ができた
んですかあこういう治療法があるんですか
としかもまある程度実験もしてあの大丈夫
だよと言われてるんだったらじゃあ私の
技術で直して見せますよということで
できるんですね現場のお医者さん
と医学部の学者さんとかチームを組んで
なんとなくいい道にだんだん進んでいくと
いう風に行くんです
よしかもま終わりはないんですね医学が
いつ頃から始まったのか最初はただ血管
ぶちって切ってみたら血が出ちゃいました
とかそんな失敗から始まってるんですけど
ねだんだんと成長して成長していって今も
まだあの成長し続けてるんですけれども先
があるかどうかも分からないんだけれども
すごくチーム組んで目指して頑張ってるん
です
ねま工学部とかね理学部なんかでも似た
ようなもんだと思うんですけれどもそれに
対して仏教学はちょっとまずいのもお
分かりですよね私も結構まずいなと途中
から気がついたんですけど最初はあの
たまたま寺に生まれたもんででま寺が田舎
の
あんまり裕福ではない寺なのでじゃあま
勉強ぐらいやりましょうかねであの学問と
してやってたんです
けどちょっと分からないんですね看聞のお
経看聞に訳されたお経とか立とか読んでて
もちっとわから
んスクの大場のものていうのも結構あり
まし
て論文とかねあの仏弟子たちが色々書いた
論文とか読んでみてもなんかちょっと
分からん私だけじゃないんですよいろんな
仏教学者がうんようわからんけれども大体
このぐらいじゃないのかなとあの自分の
見解を発表するんですねそうすると日本の
仏教会というのがまたありまして仏教会と
いうのがあるわけじゃないんですけど日本
ののお坊さんなんかも自分では修行し
ながらあるいはあの信者さんに法したり法
をやったりしながら時々は仏教の新しい
知見も仕入れなくっちゃということで自分
地で勉強したりするんですねこちらの皆
さんもすごく勉強もしておられて今こんな
にごめんなさい寝てるところごめん
ねあのやってるんですけど
でもああ今んところこうなんですねとある
程度知りながら説法したりするんですが
なんかちょっと分からんな分かりにくいな
とで分からない原因の1つが看聞に訳した
テキストっていうのがもう失われたビサガ
のテキストでその看聞の元になるものを
持ってた人たちがいないんです
ねサンスクリットならインドだからいい
だろうというわけにもいかない
サンスクリットもお釈迦様からだいぶ離れ
た時代にだいぶ離れた辺境の地域で私たち
はこういう風に教え伝えてますよと言って
たんだけどそのまんまかどうかもわかん
ないしまには大場まであの作っていって
これこそという感じで中国にまで輸出して
くれたんですけどねま分からないのも
しょうがないんですねね
元々出所がはっきりしない尋ねたくても
その人々はもういなくなってるんですね誰
がそういう風に訳したのか誰がどういう風
にテキスト作ったのかもわかんないところ
でまあ分からないよねて言いながら学者は
一応学会なんかで研究発表してその後
じゃあ渾身海だとか言ってお酒飲んで
ヘベレケになって寝ててんですねそんな
ことやってたんですけど私もその仲間の
1人だったんです
けどほの30年ぐらい前ですかね
あの本物の教え残ってますけどというま
すまなさら長老なんですけれども
テーラワーダというの私も本当に知ら
なかったんですがスリランカと東南アジア
大陸にはしっかり残ってたんですね
本当は明治の時代に日本にもある程度
伝わってきたんですけどね150年前に
その時にも日本の
仏教会がちょっと拒否反応を示しちゃって
仏教学会は結構喜んでとにかく役して内容
何が書いてあるのか調べてやるぞと全部
訳しましたね開立と経は全部日本語に訳し
て注釈書もほんのちょびっと訳してさあ
これで勉強できるぞっという時に第2次
対戦がもうとうとどうにもならなくなっ
ちゃってせっかく訳したもの燃えないよう
に地下の倉庫に隠さなくっちゃとかね当時
データで保存とかもないですからね大きな
テキストをなんとか燃やさないようにして
で戦争が終わってからもまた勉強が続いた
んですけれどもせっかくのパーリ5の響
開立の教えがうんこれはちらっと読んでみ
たんだ
けどサンバパパさあらなうん悪いことは
絶対しないぞくらっさウパサンパだ良い
ことだったらもうそれになりきるほど
頑張るぞさったパリオだな心清らかにする
ぞ当たり前じゃないで終わりなんですね
残念ながらねせっかく真実をもうこんなに
簡単に教えてもらっててもあか聞いたこと
ありますねですまされちゃってたんです
ねだってテキストだけですからねまだね
テキストはそんなに怖くないんですね自分
が嫌になって読みたくなくなったらパタン
と閉じちゃってあのいなくなっちゃえば
いいん
ですでも80年90年になって本物のお坊
さんが日本に来られてまあこういう風に
お釈迦様おっしゃってますけどと言われる
と逃げようがないんですね生承認ですから
ね恐竜の化石がいくら出てきたってまあ
大昔にはこんなものいたでしょうねぐらい
でいいんですけど本物の恐竜が今も
ジャジャンと生き残ってましたよとこれが
本物ですよって出てき
たら逃げ場がないその場合にどうしたら
いいかって言とま私たち仏教学者の反応な
んですけどね良くない反応する人は
やっぱりいやあれはテーラワーダだろう
ジブだろうお釈迦様の教えそのまんまじゃ
なくってだいぶ時間が経ってから1
グループがあの後から作り直した教えなん
じゃないかとだからあの教えでやっても
真実はまだどうせわからないから勉強する
のはやめようとあくまで目を塞ぐんです
ねあんまりいいやり方ではないと思い
ますでちょっと逃げる仏教学者もいまして
教えそのものに挑戦するんだと苦しいから
だって自分の周波の上土真州あ今本願自派
じゃなくなっちゃって仏法の法林のマーク
つけてますけどね追い出されちゃったもん
ですからでやってますけれども
あの自分の宗派の教えとちょっと合わなく
なるからかと言って仏教学は続けたいので
じゃあ歴史の分野に行きましょうとかね
新しいテキストがチベットから発見された
ぞとかあのギルギットあのインドと中国の
間のすごく山深いところの洞窟から発見さ
れたぞって言ったらじゃあそれ解読して
あげますよとかねそういう風に歴史的な
ことで色々と仏教はこういう風に日本まで
伝わってきたんだよと教えてくれる学者も
いますそれはそれでとってもありがたい
です
ねで私はどうせそういう語学の能力もない
しかと言って仏教額から離れたくないし
何よりも何か本物があるんだったらまあ
見つけてから死にたいですので
ですけどねお釈迦様が最初に教えた通りの
律と教えが残っているんだからそれただ
学べばいいだけなの
に今何やってんのかなという気が私もし
ないではないんですけど変な話です
が他のどのテキストも悟ってない人たちが
書いたんですねキリスト教のものもユダヤ
教のものもあの関東の哲学なんかも悟って
ないところから来たんですけど1人お釈迦
様の教えだけ悟るまでの教えがあの話が
全然出てこなくって悟ってからはいこれが
心理ですよとドカーンと出てきた時
に意味が分かりにくいですねやっぱりね
テキスト読むだけでは
ね皆様の前では住原長老とか部のお坊さん
が色とを解説してくださるからあなるほど
そういう意味なのかと分かっておられると
思います私の場合もあの仏教学の立場で
学者がやっぱり色々とつまづいたりして
いるところをこれこういう意味じゃない
でしょうかと自分でも分かりたいからやっ
てるんですけれども学会が
ちょっとぐにゃぐにゃとしているところに
なんか1つあをこじ開けていきたいなと
思ってるんです
ね変な話ですけどお釈迦様があの私のうれ
の話ですけどおじ様が最初に悟り開いて
教えてくださった我々はそっちに向かって
いかなきゃいけないんです
ね向かっていくのにいきなり悟と我々の間
では私の間ではすごく差がありすぎますの
であ私はこういう風に修行してますこれ
どうでしょうかとお互いに
話し合う私結構テキストあの読んできて
ますからこういう風に書いてあったんです
けどこれどういう意味か分かりますかあ
それはねと元々ボブだった我々が助け合っ
て支え合っていっ
たら解きのしておいた教え結構分かり
にくかったはずのものがなるほどなるほど
と分かっていくかもしれないんですねどの
手助けはしていきたいなと思ってま何より
私自身のためですけれども今頑張ってる
ところなんですで昨日須野サ先生が
おっしゃったんですがと私が勝手に
思い込んでいるんですけれどもただ特を
積むだけではこのまんままた輪廻が続い
ちゃいますせっかくお釈迦様が悟への道ま
本当雲の糸みたいなもんですよねたらなと
垂らしてくださっているのでなんとか掴ん
だところまで行ってそれで行きたえたら
もうしょうがないけれども心理の一遍に
達したぞぐらいまではなりたいなと考え
てるんですねそんなわけであの私も体も
小さいし今まであんまり表に出てこなかっ
たんですけれどもちょっとは木下さん
みたいにねしり出てね
あのごめんよ
がまだ不完全なまんまでも発表してあの私
はこう思うんですけどとお互いに意見を
かわし合うのが非常に大事じゃないかなと
思っていますあの教会でこういう風にあの
行事特に今日の場合はすごくめでたい行事
ですからねやってくださるんだよってなっ
たらいざ鎌倉じゃないけれども我こそはと
いう感じで参加さしていただきたいなと
思ってますこういう機会でしかもお話まで
さしていただいてありがとうございまし
[拍手]
時間がなければこれで終わりで時間があれ
ばなんか言われたら答えられますけどもう
ないですよ
ねはい楽しいお話ありがとうございました
本当にあの先輩なんだなと思いながら言い
てまし
たあの今後もあの一緒に活動できたらと
思いますんでよろしくお願いいたします
はいえっとそれでちょっとあの休憩15分
ほど取らせていただいてえっと4時ぐらい
4時からですねあの祝福のあの拠点をあ
祝福をしていただこうと思いますはい次4
時ですはい4時にお戻りくださいはい
GシップえGシップいやこれはなプロ
トレックててなんかコードコードとか気
とこ出るんですすごい見やすいですねうん
なんか
スポットライトだ
わああそう
て
はいえ祝福のえ拠点を
えお願いいたします
行こ
はいこれからあの祝福拠点あげますので
え過小席聞いてください
OV
[音楽]
UOU
μ
[音楽]
ampU
U,
[音楽]
ung
ungung
[音楽]
ampジ
ungung
ung
oment
チ-
[音楽]
ung
-
-amp
[音楽]
ung
-μ
[音楽]
チ
-
[音楽]
じゃ
-
[音楽]
amp
-
=-
[音楽]
チ
igen
-
ungU
[音楽]
U
omentamp
[音楽]
パ
tion
ungAMB
[音楽]
ung
シamp
[音楽]
チ
U
[音楽]
ジust
チ
可
我μ
[音楽]
amp
μ
[音楽]
AMB
バμ
バ
[音楽]
ampμ
μ
可
[音楽]
μ
μμ
[音楽]
μ
う
[音楽]
U
EGOAMB
ジ
ody
す
ワU
[音楽]
刺
別
ung
[音楽]
ungパ
パ
[音楽]
刺
ID
IDust
ody
*
チ
ジ
[音楽]
テ
μ
チ
[音楽]
+
ung
チ
ジ
[音楽]
-
U
[音楽]
可
-
刺
ガ
[音楽]
[音楽]
amp
パ泰
tionチ
[音楽]
U
チU
ampamp
[音楽]
amp
ン
チung
[音楽]
チamp
U
[音楽]
こ
はいえありがとうございますえっとここ
からですねあの精子と整水をえ授与して
いただきますので少々えセッティング
ございますのでお待ちください
はいそれと今日はですねあの川本さんが
作ってくださったあの誕生物の可愛らしい
仏像があるんですけれどもはいちょっと数
が微妙でございましてもしあの16日の
キノアホールにも参加いただける方は
ちょっと16日での受け取りをあのして
いただけるとあのスタッフの方中心にです
ね大変助かりますのでご配慮いただけると
大変助かりますよろしくお願いいたします
はいはいあエコーのもあそっか失礼しまし
たではあの最後にですねあのエコーのもを
え皆様でえ唱えたいと思います
はい
はいはいそれではえこの門はい意向の門ね
はいあらゆる生命に哀れみを
をれた
本のせなるえにい我々がここまで住んだ
全ての孤を神々戦争祖
親親恩を始めとし一切の息としきるものに
行いたしますこの族によって生きとし
いけるもの全てが幸福に暮らせ
そして下を得られますよう
に
さはいありがとうございます
あそうこれ
ちょっとそのもらうわそその台ください
その台
流れとしましてはあちらから順番に登って
いただきましてね祝福の糸を巻いて
いただきますそれから5正目にご移動
いただきましてお釈迦様に一連なさって
くださいそれからここに再がいますね
さ一角祭いるんですえこれを抱きしめて
いただきましてえっと抱きしめる
抱きしめる抱きしめていただきましてここ
に紙に紙に紙に書いてありますけどね再の
ごとくただ1人歩めと自分に言い聞かせて
いただいてそれからお水とそれからお釈迦
様のちっちゃなお仏道いたいてからお戻り
いただきますよろしくお願いいたします
これくくれもの忘れないにここ飛ばさない
ようにしてくださいね私持ってきて準備し
ましたのでね再のごとくただ1人歩め
抱きしめながら言ってくださいお願いし
ます
抱きしめデモンストレーションあこんな
感じで抱きしめてくださいねあのそれで
あの言葉もね再のごとくただ1人
歩めどれどれどれもいいですよ大きなの
これ結構力ある人じゃないとおこす可能性
がありますからね力自慢の人はこの大きな
のを選んでくださいであとちっちゃな2匹
いますのでねあのよろしくお願いいたし
ますそれではあの順番にえ
はい
え誕生物はあのもし16日にあの来て
いただける方はあの16日の私にして
いただけると大変助かりますご協力
よろしくお願いいたします